sir Declan we're here to talk about Alan
Partridge alpha Papa now in the movie
Alan has to live broadcast from the
scene of a siege how do you think you
would do you were faced with that
situation I find doing these interviews
tough enough so the no-show having to
broadcast live but the gun in the room I
think would scare the hell out of me but
you know in the movie Alan Rises that
challenge isn't it because that's one of
the big things that happened to him as
he starts to broadcast reluctantly
because at gunpoint but as he goes on
who realizes this is doing his profile a
lot of good news media profit side is
going huge and out of time in his life
and things aren't going great so it's a
real double-edged sword for Alan that
one absolutely in fact he did he say
it's doing his career very good evenings
isn't it and you sent and his new boss
says to him you know you're the face of
the siege I mean if you had to be the
face of said they would you like to be
the face of I am siege face oh I don't
know the face of fun hahaha that's good
that's good thinking definitely now of
course you've worked with Steve before
and it returns in his skies as Alan
Partridge how did the alpha Papa
experience compare well I work with
Stephen cruises the gods where he wasn't
playing Alan and then I did that book
reduce chauffeur he was playing Ellen
and there are very different characters
but with the movie you know a movie is a
much bigger thing than an episode of a
TV show so there's a lot more at play a
lot more at stake and so really you know
working with him on the movie for him
was very much about protecting the
purity of partridge and just giving the
script time you know on a movie you turn
apne you've got page as you shoot those
scenes but on this you play those scenes
first thing in the morning he's gone I
don't like the sound of that unless how
that C could spend a couple of hours
just tweaking rewriting scenes before
you shoot anything but that meant that
everything is shot then had been
probably partridge you know I mean it
has been through the heavens through the
testing thing and and it's Alice white
the movie i think is so funny because
they put so much care and attention and
detail into the comedy in the lines well
there's lots of cracking lines and then
it does feel very fresh in alice aim to
you before i watch the trailer up teens
I waiting in the room for the interview
and yet still feels as fresh as the
first time saw the movie now was that
you would saying about you knew tweaking
the lines you went along was there then
some improv from Steve as well along the
way her well Steve would improv maybe
when you're rehearsing a scene but then
that improv gets written down then he's
shooting you tend not to improv the
steve is very hard on himself as Alan
and it's performing because during the
middle of scene he will stop and rewind
and go back if your lens and go forward
and go back and forth on TVs he's got
something and then he might go back to
the beginning of scene again and one for
the top but we don't cut we just keep
rolling so for the other actors it is
kind of up [ __ ] he's gone back blues
gone forward you know there's that
there's a lot of a lot of fun watching
people to spawn into because he never
sure I was gonna come up with next so in
that way that's a sort of improv in a
way but it means he just runs a scene on
please happy with it now you got of
course for Alan perfect soundtrack in
there in the movie lots of great so that
roach but you've got in there you've got
a stain called Willie Nelson and so on I
mean how much do you have to do with
picking the soundtrack and which the
ones that stand out for you is
particular allen movers a lot of care
went into choosing the soundtrack and we
had a short list of about 200 song wow
that we just kicked around and listen to
and played a lot and the Edit put my
favorite the favorite song from me and
it was a track I put on at the edit one
day when we're doing a scene and it
stuck it's one of the few tracks that we
haven't changed it's very beginning to
edit and and that was Wichita Lineman
and secene ver Allen Allen and path they
really opened up to each other and Allen
poor pat pours out his heart out and
talks about his dead wife and some of
that but which the line line playing in
the background really underscores our
scene beautifully and it's one of my
favorite moments of the film is it some
great movies as well with heat with him
hahaha high society once again in on the
action here and some great moments where
Alan is you know belt along the motorway
singing along yes a lot of a thing is
shall talk about the rock yeah in bridge
how's the song conchal it up yeah come
be toy killa toy good yank
and quite near the beginning of the
scene does a quite beginning of the
films of the scene about Alan's driving
to work and on the radio they're playing
Rochford cuddly toy and he starts to my
him along to it and you think that lasts
for maybe 10 seconds are staying for two
minutes on a one-shot he just lines and
has he Minds he becomes more more
comfortable singing and he's got the
elections and things worked out to go
along with it and it is just so funny to
watch but that's a piece we had been
shooting in one location we had to move
to another and I want you to do some
driving stuff with him and he told
nobody about this I just got in the car
I had the sound guy said and he had a
track on his iphone I wanted to just
play this and I'll I'm along to it so he
played it loud in the car he didn't sing
heed his mind to it it's just fantastic
we shot three takes and we used take one
I think it's just as a piece of
performance tour de force is absolutely
superb and brilliantly funny know if you
had to pick a track that you would sing
along to either on the mohs we're in the
shower what would you like to work
belted see I was always very fond of
Chicago's if you leave me now that was
my guilty pleasure from long time ago
I'm almost done in there but we didn't
put let me put something else in the
sense what did you create it we put in a
different kind of a track hard to say
i'm sorry it's went paths just been
fired and slightly more than slightly
melancholic now creative had a
competition for the movies well to be
allen's new assistant if you were Alan's
assistant what would you bring to the
role if I was Alan's assistant only at
last very long because used to be
incredibly thick skinned and I think
he'd be quite a tough boss Finley
because I don't think he's given to
getting out much compliments finally if
you are like a lenders in the film has
to describe his colleague you can have a
sausage rolls Jordan a bit of the party
when he suddenly says that to her you
know just in the middle completely
different conversation just cut the
crosses it it's horrible isn't it
thinking of quite a little bit too /
over there with you and finally if like
a lenders in the film you had to do he
describes Pat his colleague in in 10
words we had to describe cell Alan
portrait alpha Papa to me in 10 words
how would you sell it you mean the movie
yeah the movie romance action adventure
heavy kissing it's very good exit thanks
so much no problem
you